foreign
how are you
I'm good how are you better than we
deserve what's up
well thank you guys for taking my call
to start
um so basically I purchased a home my
first home back in October and I am now
experiencing buyer's remorse
it's just been a lot of if it's nothing
it's something everything's broken
everything needs to be fixed everything
needs to be replaced
um and so I guess my question is if I
did not make the best decision how do I
make the best decision moving forward in
rectifying controlling and maintaining
my financial responsibilities
to build and so forth
so is this a fixer-upper that you bought
like are these shocking repairs or do
you know some of this going in
no um it basically that it's a house
that was built in 83 and a lot of the
renovations that were done were poorly
done
okay and this buyer's remorse is this
coming from the mortgage payment being
too big or is it all these repairs that
you don't have the cash to do where is
that coming from both
for all of the repairs and I'm ending up
having to take care of now that I've
moved in
so how much is your house payment
um right now I'm paying 18.65. okay and
what's your take-home pay a month
a month 74. okay your house payment's
not too high
okay so that's not a problem you're just
not used to paying a house payment yet
okay but it's it's in the zone of it's
it's less than a fourth of your
take-home pay so you're fine what do you
do for a living direct
I recruit for oil and gas good for you
okay well
um what uh
uh what I think is going to happen is
um that you're probably going to get the
other side of the bulk of these repairs
I don't know what exactly you've had to
fix or do what what are some examples of
the three biggest
most worrisome things that and the cost
of them that you had to fool with
um one of the one of the things I have
not started working on but it is
something that is being told that I need
to start planning is the roof
um as well the majority of the
appliances that look to be new are
having to be replaced
um insulation is completely poor I have
to have someone to come in and look at
that so those right now are just a few
of the things that I'm trying to work on
okay who told you that the roof had to
be replaced
at the time
we're about the roof and that was the
major concern when it came to you know
finalizing the purchase
it wasn't a concern enough that the VA
appraiser required a roof
right if it was bad VA would have
required a roof or they wouldn't have
put the loan on it
okay so now who told you there's it
needs a roof is it leaking
um we had a
a AC was a problem and he told me that
it was it was leaking around somewhere
in the Attic which was causing mold or
some sort he was just like it's not
major but it is something that I wanted
to look into I'm very um I'm an
overthinker um this like I said this is
my first home I'm new to all of this so
I'm panicking right now yeah and I'm
just trying to stay on top of everything
yeah
so you're a self-admitting
that you're catastrophizing okay the guy
went up there the guy went up there and
he said there's a leak and a little bit
of mold you need to get that looked at
and you went I gotta get a whole roof
right possibly so yeah yeah I mean
that's what I heard I might be wrong and
I I do that too that's how I can
recognize it so um we all have a drama
queen that lives inside of us every one
of us and part part of making good
decisions you ask how to make good
decisions is to tell the drama queen to
shut up
um and that you know that's part of it
you got to look at yourself and go
you're really come on so yeah you
probably do need to get that roof looked
at but it might be a few hundred dollars
instead of ten thousand to put on an
entire roof
it might need a little bit of a shingle
replacement there or there might be a
leak around one of the vents and they
put a new boot on it and caulk it up and
you're just fine so a good handyman
getting up there and fixing that one
area and you know shooting some stuff
killing the mold in that one little area
uh so it doesn't get worse and you don't
go up there later and the whole attic
has grown full or something like that so
yeah address it but don't over think it
and then you know all of the appliances
need look new but need to be replaced
are they not working
absolutely not what's not working your
dishwasher doesn't work
no dishwasher stove refrigerator nothing
none of them work
no did the inspector catch any of this
no did you have a home inspection
yes I had two home inspections and I had
a gas leak that was so extreme I
couldn't stay in my house for two days
and I didn't know like how I
how did y'all miss this
[Music]
okay so you're a home inspector is an
idiot okay yeah obviously right I mean
you miss a gas leak and and appliances
that don't work that's a basic thing you
go through and turn on all the
appliances this basic home inspection
stuff okay so the great news is you make
good money your house payment's not out
of control you probably don't need an
entire roof you do need a new dishwasher
have you asked Appliance to repair
people to come and just repair the
existing ones or are you just planning
to replace them completely
um I was trying to see if I had some
type of ability through my homeowners
insurance
um if that could be rectified with them
um no it's not so I'm going to have to
pay homeowners insurance doesn't cover
your dishwasher not working
so just have a guy come out and either
look at it and fix it or replace it
a few hundred bucks I mean they're not
they're not ten thousand dollars do you
have any other debt to Ray
um outside of my a little credit card
debt and a few thousand old on my car no
that's it okay and when it comes you
said we you have a spouse involved here
uh did I say we I do apologize okay it's
just you you're single okay yeah so
here's what I want you to do uh what's
happening is all of these things are up
flying around and and and just about the
time you wake up in the morning or by
the time you're about to doze off at
night they're overwhelming instead what
I want you to do is just write down a
list of what needs to be repaired and
what you're going to do about it
okay Sean okay dishwasher I'm gonna call
a repairman and if it can't be repaired
cheaply I'm going to replace it
refrigerator I'm going to call a
repairman if it can't be repaired
cheaply I'm gonna replace it roof I'm
gonna have a handyman type come out not
a roofer trying to sell me a roof that
just looks at it finds the one little
leak fixes the one little leak and
sprays some stuff and kills the mold
okay and you just you develop a list
with an action plan and when the weird
thing is if you'll write it down
literally on a yellow pad a little
repair to-do list
then you're going to look at it and it's
going to suck the drama out of your
brain
and it's going to drop right there on
that page because you're going to go oh
this is doable how because it when it
all comes at you at once it's
overwhelming creates anxiety when you
break it down into bite-sized pieces one
task at a time one broken thing at a
time you can work through an entire
remodel doing that and you don't have an
entire reason it's exchanging the
boogeyman for the repairman yeah that's
the switch here this is the your first
experience being a homeowner where you
don't call the landlord and say your
stuff's broke
instead you've got to take care of it
when it breaks it's one of the reasons
we say get out of debt have an emergency
fund before you become a homeowner
homeowner because all the stuff would
have been an inconvenience at that point
and you know you make enough money to
get through this I and no you don't need
to sell your house and really you don't
even need to have buyer's remorse I mean
there's a couple of weird things that
are here that inspector missing this
stuff but nothing here says this house
is a lemon that you're the biggest
screw-up in life because you bought it
you're a horrible person I didn't hear
any of that in this discussion you got a
couple of things broken fix them joys of
home ownership and your payment's
reasonable
fix your dishwasher enjoy the house it's
that kind of stuff just kind of put the
drama out of it put it down on the page
break it down into bite-sized pieces